[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'occasion de l'année nouvelle le
président de la République s'est adressé
à la nation
française à chacune de vous français à
chacun de vous
j'adresse du fond de mon cœur
mes meilleurs vœux de nouvel an
et puis en notre nom à tous je forme
pour la France le souhait immémorial que
l'année lui soit heureuse travailler
et rester unis
voilà
quels sont quoi qu'il arrive
les meilleurs de nos garanties
l'an dernier pour notre bien nous avons
su nous les assurer
l'an prochain qui en soit de même
[Musique]
le temps passe mais l'homme montre une
continuité rassurante dans ses idées
fixes
1962 ville et sauteurs de tonneaux
américains s'acharnaient à sauter leur
tonneau les femmes de Nola continuaient
à apporter leur pierre à un mystérieux
édifice et en Hollande les sauteurs de
canaux pour suivre leur noble exercices
bref 1962 fut une année comme les autres
et lui son festival de Cannes avec Sofia
et son moins de vacances en famille on
ne manqua pas de prodiguer les
encouragements habituels pour
l'amélioration de la race humaine
ce qui nous value des records à lui seul
Zazie en bâti 2 ceux du 3000 et du 2000
un français Charles Bozon enleva au
championnat du monde de ski le slalom
spécial
[Musique]
on ne compte pas d'année sans
catastrophe un accident ferroviaire fit
au Japon 165 morts le séisme qui secoue
la terre d'Iran provoqua le plus lourd
bilan de l'année 20.000 morts quant à la
Catalogne un déluge d'eau la transforma
par deux fois en paysage de cauchemar
50 et quelques millions de terriens ont
par ailleurs disparus dans l'année
Marilyn Monroe en pleine gloire madame
Éléonore Roosevelt l'épouse d'un des
plus grands présidents des États-Unis en
France René Coty dernier président de la
4e République
oui les mines qui avait régné 58 ans sur
la Hollande
l'immortalité ne s'est portée une fois
de plus qu'à l'Académie française ou
avec René Clair le cinéma entra de plein
droit et ça dire que 1962 n'offrit pas
quelques différences on a envie se
manifester dans le couvre-chef qui prit
une importance certaine
[Musique]
l'homme le porta avec un autre souci de
raffine et le scooteriste fut obligé de
coiffer le casque ce dont il n'est qu'à
se louer
quant au nouveau fantassins américains
il a estimé le port du casque
indispensable
[Applaudissements]
envie encore des fusées récalcitrantes
mais on sentit bien lorsque la fusée
Centaure fut détruite en vol que
l'homo-américanuce aurait le dernier mot
red Ader le pompier du pétrole n'a-t-il
pas réussi à souffler comme on souffle
une bougie l'immense flamme de 300
mètres qui brûlait agacée
le twist enfin qui continua de triompher
dans l'année a du CD des pistes au
tabouret et autres bossa nova il y avait
tout de même
d'une on le vit bien lorsque des
milliers de mains bretonnes se tendirent
vers Louison Bobet qui abandonnait le
site lis on le vit bien quand pour la
première fois depuis 50 ans le 15 de
France vaincu chez lui le 15 britannique
Jeanne d'Arc était une nouvelle fois
vangée et puis le monde avait tremblé
sur ses bases lorsque les avions
américains survolant Cuba il y avait
repéré des bases de lancement soviétique
pendant 8 jours 3 milliards d'être ont
été suspendus aux lèvres de trois hommes
Kennedy décidé
fidèle Castro prenons volontiers une
politique intraitable
chauffe enfin qui accepta le retour des
fusées
moyenne en quoi on ne parle pas trop de
Berlin
toujours en place le mur à voix de temps
à autre des faiblesses
[Musique]
les autorités de l'est sans ployèrent
alors à les combler largement
Adolf Eichmann bourreau de 6 millions de
Juifs fut livré à la potence retrouva la
justice bien douce
[Applaudissements]
à Liège par contre on applaudit au
verdict bien qu'il est acquitter Suzanne
et Jean vanne depuis des milliers de
familles avaient partagé leurs drames
[Musique]
Londres connu des dimanches agités du
fait de se reçoit le Mosley chef du
parti fasciste anglais on s'explique à
faire ma Trafalgar Square à Bruxelles
aussi du reste mais pour des raisons
toutes différentes dans le but
d'affirmer sa position en matière
linguistique le Comité d'action flamand
organisa une marche sur la capitale
pour l'Inde envahi par les troupes
chinoises 1962 a été une année
déchirante le président des routes du
t'abandonné un pacifisme dont il s'était
fait une règle d'or
quant à Monsieur Mac Millan il lui forte
affaire pour convaincre le Commonwealth
de la nécessité pour Londres d'entrer
dans le marché commun
l'Europe entre temps avait enregistré un
événement sans précédent sanctionné par
le voyage triomphale du général de
Gaulle en Allemagne la réconciliation
franco-allemande est apparue comme le
fait capital de la vie européenne
[Applaudissements]
Aaron Jean 23 dont la santé a beaucoup
inquiété le monde catholique a ouvert et
clôt la première session du concile
ecuménique Vatican 2 réunis au sommet
l'église est placée devant les grands
problèmes de notre siècle
[Musique]
1962 ce fut aussi ce fut d'abord pour la
France la fin de la guerre d'Algérie à
Évian les accords que Monsieur Jobs
signait avec Belkacem crime mirfa un
drame douloureux qui avait duré 7 ans le
retour à la première paix totale depuis
1939 n'allait pas pendant son violence à
Paris on compta jusqu'à 17 plasticages
dû à l'os dans une journée
au Petit Clamart le général de Gaulle
fut une seconde fois la cible
d'adversaires déterminée qui
déchargeèrent leurs armes sur sa voiture
[Musique]
à Alger on enregistra des destructions
spectaculaires et l'on se demanda si
l'OAS allait-il mené jusqu'au bout ce
qu'on appelait la politique de la terre
brûlée
ce ne fut que d'ultime soubresaut et le
oui des Français à la paix aboutit à la
naissance de l'État algérien indépendant
à peine née l'Algérie indépendante avait
pendant souffert d'une crise de
personnes qui devait finir au bénéfice
de l'ancien prisonnier de l'île d'Aix
Ben Bella
[Applaudissements]
mais toute cette suite d'événements
avaient eu pour conséquence le départ de
600 000 Européens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en décidant de lire désormais le
président de la République au suffrage
universel et en envoyant à la chambre
une majorité de gouvernement la France
s'installait dans une stabilité rarement
connue
le monde lever les yeux vers le cosmos
dans ce domaine l'Amérique a pris sa 20
en faisant faire un Américain trois
tours de la terre l'homme de la revanche
sa plaque
[Musique]
après lui Carpenter effectua à son tour
ces trois circonvolutions réglementaires
l'exercice semblait devenir en vente
les Soviétiques compliquèrent en
envoyant successivement pour qu'il vogue
de concerts deux de leurs astronautes et
Nicolas yef et Popovich s'acquitèrent
ponctuellement de leur mission
on en est ainsi arrivé au point confite
à peine attention à la réussite du vol
du troisième américain ce qui ira comme
dire les techniciens c'était de la
routine
mais revenons sur terre ou tout de même
jusqu'à nouvel ordre nous sommes
condamnés à vie en France la
construction de l'usine de la Rance nous
a promis l'utilisation prochaine de
l'énergie des marées
avec le commandant wow le bathyscaf a
fait un pas plus vers l'observation des
profondeurs marines en descendant à 9208
mètres dernier peut-être des
transatlantiques le France a reçu le
salut traditionnel de New York
il n'y a plus de Mont Blanc le tunnel
routier a été percé et Monsieur Pompidou
s'y est rencontré avec Monsieur Fanfani
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois les émissions de
la télévision traversée l'océan le petit
village breton de ploemeur-bodou où a
été installé le Rado mais son oreille
géante y a gagné une célébrité mondiale
mais la mondovision surtout a marqué une
date celle du début de l'utilisation des
satellites pour notre usage direct
c'est dire que les savants ont désormais
d'autres ambitions que de faire le tour
de la terre toujours en France les
radiotélescopes sans attendre les
prochains voyages sur la lune ou mars ou
Vénus ont commencé à interroger les
galaxies à des milliards
d'années-lumière
1962 peut donc encore nous faire rêver
[Musique]